good morning believe nation today's
message is believe in what you do over
to you Ryan Leslie my words of advice
are really the same words that I spoke
on when I was a teenager and I needed
money for college and so I head to the
speech competition for Rotary
International and the the the topic the
damps asked me to speak on was do what
you believe in and believe in what you
do and even now 12 years later when I
look around that's where I strive to do
every day do what I believe in and
believe in what I doing for everyone out
there that has an aspiration to do
something don't let anyone tell you what
you can and cannot do if you if you got
a dream and a goal and a passion to do
it you know I can't tell you the amount
of people that told me like look Ryan
stick to stand behind the synthesizer or
if you're gonna sing don't try to run
for if you rap don't try to sing or if
you produce don't try to be an artist so
if you if you if you if you're R&B do
don't try to go into the rock
alternative side or if you don't dance
don't try to dance or if you dance don't
you know don't decide that you're just
gonna stay behind the keyboard really
for me I think artistry the beauty and
the joy of artistry and the beauty and
the joy of just having the freedoms that
we enjoy in life is that we can pursue
anything that we want to pursue and with
the right mix of Drive desire discipline
and dedication we can achieve anything
that we want to achieve and so for all
y'all out there that have a dream I
encourage you to keep striving pushing
forward towards that dream and make it
happen man
oh wait this race to keep me go